the purpose of the provocation is to accuse Russia of using weapons of mass destruction in the Ukrainian theater of operations, thereby launching the world a powerful anti-Russian campaign is aimed at undermining confidence in Moscow according to available information, two organizations in Ukraine have a specific order to create the so-called dirty bomb the work is at the final stage we have information about the contacts of the office of the President of Ukraine with representatives of the UK on the issue of possible obtaining technology for creating nuclear weapons for this purpose in Ukraine there is an appropriate production base and scientific potential according to the plan of the Kyiv regime charge uses highly enriched uranium as a result of a dirty bomb provocation Ukraine expects to intimidate the local population to increase the flow of refugees and expose  ing the
Russian Federation
Ukraine is breaking the army of retinues so ringing to a friend,
and now Russia will have tilki
about a khachka 6 there are questions
Russian potential is being wasted
ambitions now tilki and the color of the soul has entered
the mind on the configuration of our part of non-
Eurasia the more its potential
Russia spending over growth is less real
freedom  tear off All peoples and destroy
Russia and
uimeshek Ukraine in the first
shield fish against the Highway to the Ukrainian
wash it
will be the coldest in our history the
hours of work have been earned by the sons of the bribe and the
news are still mats here are the belts of power and the
result in trims is the maximum
mobilization of our partners,
seemingly because of freedom and  this gold to our
spinal forest split globally about
democratic